there's been a lot of discussion lately
about Pete Buddha judge partially
because he's polling better and also
because he got a ton of speaking time in
the last democratic debate way more
speaking time as we analyzed then the
level of polling support he had at the
time would have predicted and this is
yet another sign that the establishment
and corporate legacy media are
interested in pushing the establishment
centrist candidates over other
candidates but what I want to talk about
today is how pushing Budaj edge is
actually a really safe thing to do for
the establishment and corporate media
because you might think hold on a second
if the establishment wants a centrist
they should be pushing Biden he's
already leading in the polls and you
might think not unreasonably if the
establishment starts pushing mayor Pete
that could take away support from Joe
Biden and it could lead to a Bernie
nomination or it could lead to a war in
nomination so it's risky for the
establishment to divide support between
Budaj edge and Biden if what they
ultimately want to do is prevent Bernie
or Warren from being the nominees which
i think is pretty clear as what they
want to do but I don't believe this is
the way it's actually going to play out
partially because remember that the
primary process doesn't happen all at
once and partially because people
getting comfortable with Budaj
helps them get comfortable with Biden -
so I'll explain to you how this all
works as a reminder Pete Budaj
is now polling an average of between
about eleven and twelve including in one
poll 16% way up he was at four percent
four and a half percent a few months ago
so he has roughly tripled his support
now in the meantime we have seen both
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren fall in the
polls here is how pushing Budaj
is safe for the establishment and in the
end it probably helps Biden retain his
spot at the top of the polling by
pushing Budaj the establishment is
generally pushing establishment centrism
over the ideology of folks like Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren so once you
are in the mindset once you're in the
universe of considering Pete Budaj
his general ideology becomes sort of
your status quo starting point
almost
foregone conclusion but you might start
to say you know I'm all-in with Buddha
judges ideology but is he electable is
he too young does he have enough
experience merely having been mayor of
South Bend Indiana but that's the the
strategy if you become comfortable with
Budaj edge on policy thanks to the
establishment pushing him and you vote
for him in a primary and maybe he wins
some early primaries and has a path to
the nomination even if he doesn't win
your natural transition is to Joe Biden
once you're in the universe of centrism
once you've bought that bill of goods as
the ideology that you want to support
for the Democratic primary if you start
to question Budaj edge because of his
lack of experience or age or other
factors and then you say I'm gonna look
for somebody else
the obvious choice becomes Biden Biden
is a centrist like Buddha judge with
more experience and having held more
prominent political office and what I
mean by the way but but when I say the
obvious choice is Biden I don't mean the
obvious choice for me I don't mean the
obvious choice for progressives I mean
once you want centrism but with more
experience than mayor Pete it's a very
easy transition to go over to supporting
Joe Biden going Budaj edge to Bernie or
even Budaj edge to Warren is less of a
smooth transition and this is why
corporate legacy media pushing Pete
Budaj edge where it's unclear if Biden's
got it together his performances and
debates haven't been good it's win-win
either you push Budaj edge as the Biden
alternative and prevent people from
going to Warren or Bernie or you simply
are pushing centrism and in the end you
end up reinforcing Joe Biden and really
what you want to do if you're the
establishment corporate legacy media and
the DNC insiders you want to deny Bernie
the nomination you want to deny
Elizabeth Warren deity nomination let me
know what you think this is how I am
increasingly seeing it send me a tweet
at D Pakman leave me a reply as a
comment if you're watching on YouTube
the next video is coming soon but before
you go to that please hit subscribe and
like we're running a test we believe
that if everybody does this this
we'll hugely boost us in YouTube's
algorithm and then everybody wins I'll
report back to you how this works make
sure before you go on to that next video
hit subscribe hit like thank you so much